what's going on guys the first trailer
for my hero academia season five has
just dropped
uh more specifically it's a teaser
trailer so it's literally about
30 seconds long but um i woke up this
morning and i just saw that it had been
uh
tweeted out and i'm i'm just so hyped
right now it's ridiculous
i've included a link in the description
for anyone who wants to check it out
i've seen it about three times now so
i'm just gonna give my
i want to say my immediate reaction but
i've seen it three times but um
i mean to start with shinzo looks
absolutely great
leica i'm just looking at it now the
mask looks almost perfect
the the colors are pretty much in line
with what we saw in the manga
uh that manga cover for volume 23. so
yeah it looks really nice really high
quality
and my boy he's gonna get some big shine
this season so i'm very happy for him
um he was the thing i was most excited
for uh but i mean class one b in general
like
not that shinzo's in class 1b but um
class 1b in general they've been done
a lot of justice in this trailer they
get a lot of screen time
and one interesting thing is that we see
the entire class
in color in their hero costumes for the
first time ever
this glue guy in the back i i never
thought about what is what color his
costume was but
it wasn't that like i didn't picture a
red and yellow costume looking hella
bright
but um no it doesn't look too bad um
mushroom girl as well her costume looks
really nice in color
um we have seen that in like uh that i
think she was in the
on the back of one of the manga volumes
i think but yeah it looks really nice in
color
i forget this girl's name i think it's
set sooner but yeah purple
that looks good that looks good
nurengeki as well his costume looks
awesome
looks like something out of one of the
terminator movies or or something like
that
but no everyone looks good in class 1b
and we get a few action shots from them
so
i'm them literally doing stuff my
favorite one was beast grabbing
hiroshima
and froppy as well because beast like
we'd seen him before in the sports
festival
as i guess with everyone um but he
didn't really do much but in this
in this season he will get some cool
moments and this
frame specifically was one of the
moments he really was shining and if you
can see in the little corner there
shinzo's hair is there as well so yeah
we get another shot of ibara in action
using her vines
um and i'm not going to give her any
spoilers in this video but yeah she she
uses them quite well from what i recall
um although i haven't read the joint
training arc for for a minute now
um but yeah this is all just so great
this is actually happening because i
know we got the news
the rumor about the release date early
this week that is now confirmed it is
coming out in spring
which is what i believe you know i think
it's going to be april of 2021
um and now yeah it's all confirmed the
trailer didn't give away any spoilers in
terms of
the whole joint training arc like when
you look at this shot for example
it doesn't actually show you who's
paired up with who like it's not
accurate
so um yeah it's just showing you who's
involved but it's not giving away any
plot points
so i liked it for a tz trailer not bad
at all
i was just so happy to see this animated
like to see them actually moving
and knowing that this is coming um
because the i remember that feeling of
season four where every week you get a
new episode
i just missed that and i can't wait to
get back to it um so yeah
really happy about this uh link is in
the description if you want to check it
out
and if you want me to do a breakdown of
the trip if i know i can't do a
breakdown of this can i
maybe i can i don't know if you want me
to do a breakdown let me know in the
comments below but
no harm if you don't want me to do it
because it is 30 seconds but yeah i want
to see if there's demand for it
um but anyway thank you guys for
watching and be sure to watch the
trailer
let me know your thoughts are you as
hyped as i am um and yeah until the next
one
peace out